you know what makes me sick all this
america-first crap from Donald Trump but
the federal government spends taxpayers
money we should use it to buy American
products and support American jobs
during my first term alone will invest
400 billion dollars in purchasing
products and materials our country needs
to modernize our infrastructure hmm wait
wait wait did he just say use it to buy
American products I wonder where he got
that idea in my administration we live
by two simple rules by American and
higher America by American and higher
American by American and higher American
I've been saved by American ever since I
announced I was running for office and
long before that true well maybe that
wasn't such a bad idea after all mr.
Trump another one of those messy moments
when he turns out to be right all along
just wait until Biden asks for a wall so
the rest of us have caught up to trump
for example we now realize China is
engaging in war against America and it's
not a cold one but a sleek lab built hot
war that destroys an economy and
disrupts political life with a weapon
more modern than a bomb and minus the
messy retaliation but I thought Joe was
known for sticking to his guns I mean it
was his days ago that he was barely able
to say this this guy's whole idea of
America America on its own is men
America alone we're out there by
ourselves how can you not remember the
second word in America first and sorry
Joe creating a policy that stresses
buying American goods over non American
goods is actually putting America first
but I get it he's got a lot on his mind
plus it's all covered with plugs I mean
what does Lonny know Lonny knows I
believe this every fiber might be we're
posed what I proposed is is it can be
done I think we're in a position
to really make it happen and my team in
your team already working closely
together and like to light up the path
forward here critical laws like the
proact to strengthen collective
bargaining i'm politics like prevailing
and true look I guess I'm getting I'm
taking too much time but yes you are I
have no idea what he just said lover
hate Trump his sentences actually
connect two dots often loudly but Joe's
words are just like Joe always in danger
of wandering off into the woods but
maybe that's the strategy you can't
criticize what cannot be deciphered
so text Joe at one eight eight eight I
forgot the rest where's my soup so Jesse
you once said that why should you vote
for Joe Biden if Joe Biden is gonna be a
trump light is this an example of him
being Trump light yeah I mean he
plagiarized by American higher American
basically it wouldn't be the first time
Joe Biden plagiarized in politics but I
don't care I think it's actually great
that both candidates from both parties
have a more economic nationalist
populist approach to the US economy
so if Biden moves to the right on this
good it moves the conversation in the
right direction because this is where
the conversations going it's going to be
a less multilateral world we're gonna
have more of a kind of a gunboat
mercantilism if you guys know what I'm
talking about where we're gonna protect
our own shipping with our own navy not
protect the entire world's free trade
with our Navy those days are over the
Cold War is kind of crumbling and we're
kind of getting back to American first
and Trump was right about it now Joe's
gone far left on the environment and
he's gone far left on the defund the
police so I honestly don't know where
Joe is at any given moment and neither
does he
Lorenzo drop in the mercantile in the
other spots one so now we have two
Republicans running for
that's got to be good news well you
can't say that these puppet of the
left-wing but here's my take on this you
know president Crump's ratings are
pretty low right now they've gone down
but the one area in which he still it
pulls very well and gets the approval
American people and it's his ability to
handle economic issues people see him as
someone who can do that and I think Joe
Biden and his campaign are speaking to
that strength right now in saying well
let's look at manufacturing let's look
at mining let's look at some of the
issues like farming has that gotten
better it has president Trump lived up
to all the promises that he made about
reviving those economic sectors and
saying no and if you would like Joe
Biden Joe Biden says he in fact will
make real on those promises those fail
promises that came from Donald Trump
that's a big difference to offer a
positive vision
I think the slogan they have is build
back better and I think what it is is
saying hey I can really deliver on the
economy where the incumbent has not do
it it's a positive agenda and I think
you know you think back to the tax cuts
the whole thing that led to buybacks for
the big corporations that enrich the
very rich in our country didn't bring
back wages or jobs and I think he's
saying that was a failed economic
package and here's an opportunity to
actually bring to life what the what
President Trump had been talking about
so it's not plagiarism it's saying let's
actually do it and get it done you know
Dana who knew that Joe Biden is a
jingoistic white nationalist well think
about where he gave the speech today is
not what Mania Pennsylvania is going to
be the main battleground state I think
coming up in this three-and-a-half
months when on election day and so Joe
Biden is has some work to do especially
in these counties where he was today I
understand that voter registration for
Democrats is down about 20 percent
so if he wants to try to find voters who
went from Obama to Trump and he wants to
try to get them back to his corner he
has a work to do and so that's one of
the reasons that you saw him go out
there and do this today the other thing
that happened is that Bernie Sanders
invited have been working their staffs
have been working on these committees to
try to figure out where might they be
able to agree and instead of moving to
the center as general election
candidates usually do Joe Biden
continues to move more to the left maybe
not on this economic issue in particular
but I think that Bernie Sanders would be
very comfortable with by American hire
American like that's like that's his
whole world the other thing is that
Biden as soon as he as soon as the Trump
campaign starts to focus on pushing him
to where he is and say he's so far left
and he's gonna go in further left he
likes what Bernie likes he wants to give
health care to illegal immigrants he's
going to do the green New Deal
all the way we're going to eliminate all
these jobs in Pennsylvania it just
relentlessly focusing on how Biden will
actually be beholding to the left seems
to me to be where the Trump campaign to
try to focus in the next few weeks what
do you think Kennedy I'm not a big fan
of populism on either side but it's
especially dangerous when it comes from
the left because it breeds this
authoritarianism and then the economy is
really going to go down the toilet
because what they're going to do is have
these federal mandates on on what you
can buy and who you can buy it from it's
not just a sense of goodwill that I want
to help out American manufacturers and
and workers and Americans who have great
idea and buy their products and services
it is going to be done by force so when
you increase spending they're also going
to increase taxes there is no greater
certain way to tank the economy than to
marry those two devils and and that's
what Joe Biden is doing with this and
when he's working in concert with Bernie
Sanders who is an avowed socialist it is
horrible news for the economy and I
think the more bite moves up in the
polls the worse it's going to be for the
markets and they're really going to
start
acting to that and also it's all it's
always Dana can tell you this it's
always a great idea to steal whatever is
working from your opponent but if the
president were to steal something from
Joe Biden what is it
what is his phrase or his idea or the
the foundation of his ideology that is
so popular and is working so well that
the president would want to borrow from
that I can't think of anything yeah
neither can Joe